April is financial literacy month yes it
is Mercedes spoke with president and CEO
of
Silver State Schools Credit Union Scott
AR kills to find out how their um how
they're helping the sponsors of the
segment
April is financial literacy month what
is that and when did it come about so
financial literacy awareness month was
actually established in 2004 and it's it
was created to emphasize the importance
of budgeting and investing and at any
stage of life so even though we should
all practice Financial Wellness uh goals
every day financial literacy month as a
reminder to review those goals and to
really stay on track with our financial
success
why is financial literacy so important
to you and Silver State Schools Credit
Union that's great question Mercedes
well at Silver State Schools Credit
Union we are your financial partner for
life that is our mission statement quite
frankly and so as a non-for-profit
financial institution we're always
invested in Our member owners and their
financial success
um and and we do that by providing
resources such as our money moves
Financial education center that actually
uh you helped participate in and the
last one which was a great event and
also our Balance Financial fitness
program
um balance is uh uh it's on our website
and it is something that I've uh carried
with me at every uh Credit Union that
I've worked for over uh 15 years and
it's a fantastic program that teaches
financial literacy uh and and it's just
great it's it's free to all members um
and and quite frankly also as an added
benefit all of our member deposits are
safe and insured and given what's
happening with the banking debacle and
svb bank and everything
um I want to emphasize that every
deposit account not just every member is
privately insured up to five hundred
thousand dollars per account so what
that means for example if you're at an
FDIC bank or an ncua Credit Union your
funds are insured up to 250 000 per
member if you take that same example
um and our member has four accounts and
they're up to five hundred thousand
dollars each they're actually insured
through our private insurance up to two
million dollars what is the Silver State
Schools Credit Union doing to celebrate
financial literacy awareness month so
we're partnering with one of the high
schools to provide what's known as a
byte of reality event for their entire
our senior class why they call that
fight of reality is because uh it it's
it's set up to not make it easy for
these students it's it's to give them
real life examples of things that go
wrong and how you can overcome them with
uh with really financial literacy and so
um and and and we're also excited to
have you join me for our first financial
literacy webinar
um we couldn't be more uh pleased that
you're going to join us uh with that as
our ambassador we think that's going to
be a fantastic thing
um as you know because you were there
this past Friday several people won cash
at our mobile literacy truck at our
Water Street branch in Henderson and and
uh we're very excited to announce our
financial literacy truck we'll make
another appearance at the end of April
and we'll give you more details on on
that but we'll also award more cash and
teach more about financial literacy
thank you to Silver State Schools Credit
Union for sponsoring this segment visit
silverstatecu.com or call
702-733-8820 for more information we'll
be right back